ام
[موسيقى]
بدات مرحله جديده من المواجهات في الموسم
التاسع من نجوم العلوم
اليوم سيحدد مصير ثلاثه مشتركين لجنه
التحكيم تتقدم بثبات
البروفسور فؤاد مراد الدكتور خالد العالي
الدكتور عبد الحميد الزهيري
ولقاء الود يتسبب في هذا الموسم مع خالد
الجميلي السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اهلا بكم عشاق العلوم اليوم ندخل مرحله
جديده تصفيات بناء النموذج هذه المرحله
دقيقه هو صعبه ضيفنا اليوم عاشها وخرج
منها منتصرا معنا نجم علوم الموسم الثاني
نجوم العلوم
[موسيقى]
حياتي محطات كثيره بس نجوم العلوم ايام
مسيره
الهاوي في النادي العلمي الكويتي لكن
الحين دخلت مجال الاحتراف
الفين وعشره ولاده جديده
نجوم العلوم
علمي ايضا من مائه كل واحد عم
حصلت واز عديده في الاجتماعات جنيف
اليابان الاختراع الجديد حول الاسواق بقوه
المعرفه التكنولوجيه في الكويت تحتاج الى
روايه عندي مسؤوليه شباب مبتكرين اساعدهم
في تحقيق الاحلام
مشروع جديد نرجع ننطلق فيها
قاسم مشترك الكويتي الفائز باحد مواسم
نجوم العلوم معنا اليوم ترجع مره ثانيه
لبيتك في قطر نجوم العلوم بقول لك حياك
الله
شو اخبارك اليوم الاعمال مبتكر مقترع ولا
حكومي اداري في هذا مع بعض الحمد الله من
بعد برنامج
بالضبط في مركز صباح الاحمد ال بدا الرئيس
قسم من تطوير الاختراعات
وايضا في تحت اه شبكه لتطوير المنتجات حق
القطاع الخاص في الكويت والاليه اللي
تعلمتها من برنامج نجوم العلوم وهي
استخدمتها والضغط الشركه والتي قاعد تشتغل
على القطاعات نرجع في كليه برنامج نجوم
العلوم بين الجد والهزل هي لجنه لجنه
تحكيم وفي بعض الاحيان يقال انها لجنه
التحقيق صادق رايك هي لجنه التحكيم صحيحه
ولجنه تحقيق اللي ما يكون مع نفسه ويكون
مقتنع ان هذا موضوع ي يعني يطرحه هذه
التجربه حقيقيه والان ان شاء الله كل
التوفيق على عموم صادق اليوم على ثلاثه
مذكرين يحضرون انفسهم لمواجهه لجنه
التحكيم اعضاء هذه اللجنه جاهزين ايضا بعد
اجتماع مع الخبراء الاطلاع على تفاصيل
المشاريع
المتنافسه تقرير فاصل قبل المواجهات
ان مجموعه خليجيه بامتياز في عنا محمد من
قطر وسام من السوريه واحمد من الكويت في
عندنا تصميم صناعي صحيح وانما كمان في
اداء هندسه شو عملوا برايي مشرفين على
الاختراعات اثنين من
احمد نبيل
محمد الجفيري من بعد حلها الشغل والتعب
احنا كل شيء ساعه
انجلس تايمز
اليوم عم ندافع عن المشروع مشروع
ان شاء الله شوفوا مين يستغل فيما استغل
لازم كمان نسمع للمتسابقين عندي انا بعض
الاسئله اللي هي بت حسم الموضوع بالنسبه
لانه الحرب شوف كيف ما يدافعوا عن افكارهم
وعن منتجاتها شو اثبت وهون شهرين
[موسيقى]
اهلا متابعين ايضا على موقع البرنامج
كما صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيسبوك وايضا
كتب تشير الدراسات الى ان عدد الاطفال
الصم في الوطن العربي يتخطى حاجز ال مائه
وخمسين الف طفل ويشكل تعليمهم تحدي تربوي
كبير محمد الجفيري قرر دخول التحدي واقترح
لله
يوم
الموضوع
[موسيقى]
هذه
والتعلم يتطلب منها طاقه كبيره في لغه
الاشاره معقده وصعبه
[موسيقى]
عائده تحتاج وقت م م جهود لانها
لتسهيل عمليه تعليم الاطفال محمد
لمساعدتهم
[موسيقى]
باسلوب
اخطاء عائده وفي الوقت نفسه يكون التعليم
محمد
الاسرى تواصل
[موسيقى]
منافسه
المستقبل
ان شاء الله
شخصيه معروفه في قطر متعدد المواهب
في اعداد القاده
في
المجتمع
وانا وانا
المهام
الفريق ويعطينا
للاطفال
هذا الشخص عمل حركه معينه من خلال
الكاميرات ان قار هذه الحركه في الحركه
الاصليه اللي في القاعده زيارات عندنا
فاذا كانت معموله بشكل صحيح الربوت راح
يقول له صح لغه الصمت اما الى الثاني
عملها بشكل خاطئ وراح يقول لك
ولكن يستطيع
محمد
الادوات اللازمه
[موسيقى]
بالضبط
هذا محمد لخطه العمل الاولى
معقوده على تفاعل الاطفال مع
احنا اليوم
عشان نقدر بعدين
[موسيقى]
مجرد ما شفت الولد قاعد يلعب مع الربوت
قاعد يسوي الحركات والاشارات
وكان جهاز عمله اه يعني فيه فائده ومساعده
بنسبه عاليه ولكن فيه مشكله الجهاز
[موسيقى]
لعب وعلم طفله ضغوط التعليم ال الى
التفاعلي للاطفال السمو مع محمد الجفيري
السلام عليكم جميعا محمد كونك وافكار كثير
حلوه ومهمه انه يقرا منصه تفاعليه للمجتمع
ال يعني خاطبوا ويتفاعل معه
مهمه ولكن ليست اختراع لهجوم والعلوم وكان
من الصعب نتاكد انه محمد ما قال فكتب
ولانه عم يعملها الكميونتي بقلب لو لو
الهدف وانا بدي اعمل شهاده هون انه محمد
بخلال نجوم وال ورشه العمل التزم بالمهام
اللبنانيه من
برشلونه بالاسئله محمد اللي اذا عندك شيء
اضافه الى اللي احنا سمعناه ولكن
وانا حبيت اني اكون من اول سيد نبدا فيه
نجوم العلوم واليوم اقول لك
انا بتشرف هايدي شغله فيها كثير من الشباب
الواعد والواعي لمستقبل ان الله راد بيروح
لو من صغري ونطالع الدكتور فؤاد من قبله
يشعره ويصير الابيض انا قاعد اقول هذا هو
الراي الموجود اتمنى من الشعب ان يكون فيه
يعني انا اول واحد شو رايك من زملائي اللي
بيكون تستغلوا بيصير فعلا حميد مثلا يعني
في تحدي اكيد في تحدي محمد اللي هو اختراع
جديد ومفيد هو كلمه واحده انت الاكثر لانه
بالاخر ممكن تجيب فيديو
الاطفال يتعلموا منه حتى ان هناك هذا
السؤال
صحيح سؤالي لالك دلوقتي بتعتبر انت هذا
الروبوت هذا البروتوتايب اللي انت عملت
فيه انتراكتيف انه احنا بس نحط فيديو قدام
هذا الربط هذا يساعد الطفل ان يتعلم حركات
جديده واشارات جديده هذا الربو اه احنا
قدرنا من خلال تجربتنا انه احنا ناخذ عن
طريق الكاميرا الاشاره عند الطفل وان
قلتها في الفيديو اللي شفناها كان فيه خطه
ثانيه
وما مشت عليه ممكن ممكن تقول لي ايش كانت
الاسباب دكتور خالد في بدايه البرامج
الاولى قلت لي انا باحط له نوع لسبب واحد
انتو كاداره تعمل
تتفاعل مع الطفل تذكر ولا لا
اليوم انا بملك اليس لنا سويناها
ام بي سي
توجد ما مش كلها منهم الفعل ان اطرح عليك
سؤال
اليوم انت انا برايي انك وصلت لدرجه ما
اتفق عليه يمكن تحسن اذا شركه اخر سوى
لو احنا كان الاكثر حتى وصل فيه تخيل انه
عندك ابن زعلان وهو قاعد في غرفه حزين
وانت تناديه وهو اصم وتقول له تعال تغدا
الروبوت يعمل الاشاره لل ولد فال ولد يرد
على الروبوت الروبوت يرد على الام او الاب
و انا زعلان هذا اللي ممكن نصلي من خلال
هذا البروتين انا عندي بعض الاسئله كانت
اكد ان كانت الطائف بالمجال الى اخترتوا
الاردن
على ظهره شويه
هذه عباره عن كفر داخل لبنان لهذا الجهاز
اللي هو اللقطه فعليا هذا البروتوتايب
يعتبر الف في النهايه احنا ما راح نستخدم
هذا البطل يكون فيه شيء ما بعرف اليوم
يعني حتى الساعه طبعا ما فيه
الامور عند مطلع على النتيجه طبعا اصحاب
الاختصاص وقالوا بها المنتج ما توقعت انه
فيه ثاني يعني
الله يستر للاسف انا كان ودي ان تتواصل مع
اعرف ايش اللي صار هايده
بنشوفها نحنا وياه يعني خائف جدا من
النتيجه
التردد واننا سوف عدم حصوله على الفرصه
نحنا نعكس هذه النتيجه بالارقام بالعلامات
ان شاء الله يا الله خلينا نشوف
هدف محمد ان يسخر اخر ما توصلت اليه
التكنولوجيا
للتعليم الفعال
جوده التعليم يحددها مستخدم الجهاز
يتعلم والحركات
ثلاثه
انا كنت مقصود جدا انه طالب ما استغرب
الفكره بالعكس تفاعلوا معها بشكل سريع
الجهاز شكله حلو ممتاز
رده الفعل الجهاز لما كان يطلع الحرف
والطالب يحكي الحرب صحيح كان يحيي الجهاز
بالشكل هذا هذه تحيه الصنف
احنا حاولنا انه يعني الحرب خطا كنت انتظر
رده فعل الجهاز ما كان فيه رده فعل
هاي بتسوى انا عندي فجوه بين الجهاز وبين
مبدا احنا ما كان عليه حلوه جدا لكن في
المستقبل بدايه طور اكثر من هيك بدو
تعديلات كبير الجهاز
محمد يعطيك العافيه الرموز في نهايه الاخت
ما تفضلت لكن انت بالنسبه لك انت الان ام
هل عندك تعليق على نتيجه اختبار اللي
وصلنا له خلال شهرين في نجوم العلوم هو
بالضبط اللي كان الدكتور فؤاد والحمد لله
نجحنا في الخطوه الجايه راح تكون اصعب
بكثير شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لكم الخير
العمليات الجراحيه التقليديه تتم اليوم
بواسطه المنظار الجراحي لهذا التطور بعض
المعوقات احمد نبيل الطبيب تصدى لها واجرى
تعديلا يحسن من عمل الجرائم
اليمين
[موسيقى]
العدسه
احمد نظيف الطبيب يعرف جيدا هذا العالم
ادخل تعديلا على المنظار الجراحي يقوم
بتنظيف عدسه النظر تلقائيا لرؤيه واضحه
كما يسود المطار ب مؤشر ضوئي افتراضي يشير
بدقه الى اي موضع في الجسم ابتكار احمد
خطوه جديده نحو السلامه والدقه
[موسيقى]
احمد في الدوحه كانت من السلطه الطويله
انتو صغير مميز هلا التميز بين مما يزيد
احمد نظيف طبيب ليس كبار الاطباء مشهور
ومعروف وناشط على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
متابعون بالالاف مؤثر في وسط
موجود
تنظيف العدسه والقيم او الضوء الافتراضي
في العمليه التعليميه
العمليه
مش موجودين اليوم
من هلا لشهرين بدنا نموذج شغال يثبت انه
هذا المبدا
[موسيقى]
اه صراحه
لدى احمد اسئله كثيره كي يستكمل ابحاث
وكانت له زياره ل مستشفى حمد العام التابع
لمؤسسه حمد الطبيه
هل تتكرر عليك المشكله في عدم الرؤيه بشكل
واضح بتصير عندنا هالمشاكل شويه عطلنا عن
العمليه لو لمست العدسه المريض تعمل
الفوضى الى منصه الدم بيطلع على برا
ننظفها نحنا نتعايش مع ها المشكله من زمان
يحل ها المشكله اكثر في الموضوع انه حط
فيها وينتر ممكن يشوفوا الاشاره تبقي
الاشاره قفزه في عالم التعليم والتدريب
والتقليل الوقت
احمد
في تطوير المنظار الجراحي جمعيه اطباء رهن
اشارته صباح الخير انتاب العمليات يعتمد
التعديل الانسب في الاستخدام
ان حتى الجيش على ناحيه اللي ناحيه اليمين
الحين احنا
وصلنا
[موسيقى]
يعرفوا ما يريد يقوم يوميا اختبارات
متعدده مستخدما مواد متنوعه الهدف
السائل وتنظف المشكله انه
[موسيقى]
سهوله
المشاكل هاذي خليك خليك خليك من
المشاكل
قبل الانتهاء من تطوير
نتائج
كانت واحده والاهم نجاحها على ارض الواقع
في مركز تدريب
اللي
انا واحد من الناس
فيها نوع من انواع السلام
[موسيقى]
انا
تحمس كثير لكن انا صراحه ان بحرب جدا
بالنموذج الاولى اللي رومانيا احمد واعتقد
انه راح يكون لها مستقبل جدا جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
ضبابيه بعد اليوم المؤشر الافتراضي
الجراحي ينظف تلقائيا مع احمد نبيل
تقرير واضح تجارب مختلفه تحد كبير في مجال
حساس جدا جدا
ونحنا محظوظين معنا عضو لجنه الحكام
الطبيب شو هو المشكله ان انت عايز احنا
عندنا مشاكل كثير عندنا ضبابيه في المجال
الفيل الجراحي عن
كمان انه اتفاق مع الدم او اللي تنسقها
المنظار ان مؤشر للتدريب ان تحاول تعمله
عشان يعلم شباب الاطباء والطلبه انت
بالضبط النهار ده اللي انت وصلت
الفكره كانت في البدايه انا اخذ المنظار
الجراحي نفسها يغير شكله او اطلع باداء
جديده مختلفه تماما
بتعديلات
ما يغير شكل ولا غير طريقه استخدامها لكن
بنفس الوقت اعالج اكبر قدر من المشكلات
اللي انا اقدر احل ها هي المشاكل اللي
احمد انا بسالك سؤال محدد ما هي هذه
المشاكل تنظيف العدسه يعني احنا الفين
وسبعه
خير ان ان الفين وسبعه عشر ينزل من
السياره عشان تمسحها وتذكر سياره لانه ما
فيها وما في اعداد التلقائيه هذا حالنا في
العمليات احنا بالفين وسبعه
لازلنا ثمانيه الشغله الثانيه انا كينيا
في غرفه العمليات وحتى لما كنت ما ذكر
السودان بصراحه كنت اتابع مدى معين في
العمليه بعدين اضيق عندهم خبره في
العمليات في الشاشه وعارفين كل شيء
يتكلمون بسرعه ويشرحون بسرعه ولقيت ان هذه
المشكله موجوده معاي انا شخصيا بدايه اللي
حوالين الموجوده معكم المشكله
انا
يعانون من نفس المشكله يعني النووي انت
اختراعك النهائي سيكون امام نظر جراحي ولا
انت اختاريت وثلاثين بالنهايه هناك احمد
ما راح صنع
ربما يسال في هذا شيء الحمد لله الحمد لله
اكيد يعني
الدكتور زهير يعني بين لجنه التحكيم اللي
عنده نفس المجال اكبر
وانت جربت هذا الاقتراع
جربتها على وايد اشياء جربتها على كشف
خاصه اعلى من الدم والدين ستي اعلى من
دراسه الدم
وستين الف مره على من
فاذا انا انه اكتشاف فاكيد انا
الخصائص الفيزيائيه مطالبه جدا للبلاد
فجرت
انجليزي ان الدكتور عبد الله الانصاري كان
عندها تخوف من الفائته كثير يا
على ال على اللمس تجربتنا الكنديشن اللي
انا محتاج لكن للاسف يحمل داخل مع المريض
ما فيه ولا
نحن اعطينا ال يعني الاولويه للدكتور
الزهيري يعني راح تحت
انا حكيتها الحديث يعني
دكتور خالد انت عندك ابتكار لذلك الخيار
واحد منهم بس اي واحد
سؤال سؤال
وهذه ثلاث ثواني هي النفس اللحظه اللي
اللي فيها تفضل هذا وهذا
تفكر فعلا ان اقول حاجه اي اختراق اكثر
انا
التنظيف التنظيف نفسه انا حسنا فعلا مشكله
حقيقيه بس ايضا الكويت يعني ما اقدر تخلى
عنها لانه على الطبيب في هذا المجال
المراتب هذه المراحل كنت مرحله التعليم
والتدريب هذه اذا تفكر من ناحيه ال خلينا
نقول ايدها بتشتغل مع شركه هي الصنع
وتخاطبهم
امكانيه تنفيذ
انا التنظيف
بين مصابه
[ضحك]
هذا موضوع الدكتور فؤاد
ما اتوقع المشروع مائه بالمائه ملك
الدكتور احمد
وان تمشي بالتنظيم كان داخلي
واحد الثاني راح تعطي اقل اهميه هذا الشيء
احمد
[تصفيق]
دكتور الاجابه
شو هي الشروط المثاليه وقت اللي بتكون
الكاميرا شغاله وما في ابو ظبي الشروط
المثالي بالنسبه للحراره
ان الاستاذه
صراحه الارقام ما تحضرني
انا دائما عندي قاعده ان الفكره منك تحفظ
الفكره انك تعرف توصل المعلومه مثل ما
تحتاجها وتعرف
هل انتم على ان تتغلب انتم عملت حاجه بين
الدكتور زهير الضبابيه ال المشكله تصير
لما يصير فيه
وتغلب عليه انها تقلل قال ان تستخدم
من ظبي مع انه ما في شيء وسخ المجمد في
بدايه هل يملك ليونس ان بين طفلان الجواب
انه ينظف الفوق بس كان يسحب وستين
الصحون
بيعمل كل شيء نحنا بدنا نشوف شو رايك
الخبراء يا اللي عم انا اعرف ان كانت
الحوزات الطبيه انا بكره ولكن انا اطلقت
هذا الفحص العلمي يشوف شو عم
لاثبات فعاليه منظار احمد نبيل اختبار
دقيق تقوم به مجموعه اطباء في مؤسسه حمد
الطبيه في قرار
نحن نعرف المنظار الجراحي الاشياء اللي
فعلا تؤدي الى التفاهم وان قارنا بالوقت
مع اختراق
نعم
اوكي
الحين طبعا ب نستخدم الزراعه احمد
المشكله اللي شفناها كانت العدسه طرحه
شويه وراء
لسقوط العدسه الى ان احنا نعمل عمليه
التنظيف بال معينه دائما نقطه من الماء
تكون موجوده كانت تعمل لنا ضبابيه على
الصوره بالرغم المشاكل التقنيه لوجهه
اختراع احمد يقول لي واجهناها اليوم
اختراق جدا واحد وانا كجراح
اعتقد انا لو توفر لها الاقتراح يكون سعيد
جدا استخدام
احمد يعطيك العافيه
الدكتور استخدم كلمه الله يبدو ان بنفس
الوقت ما يبغي اظلمت لكن بعد ما هيك بنفس
الوقت وتعبر بنفس الوقت عن خيبه من خلينا
نقول انتخاب امريكا اه انا برايي ان
الجراح يجرح ما يهم بكل صراحه هنالك ان
شاء الله كل التوفيق شكرا جزيلا لك
بقي لدينا لهذه الليله مشترك ثالث يحلم
بالتاهل اللجنه لن تبقى كلمتها قبل
المواجهه الاخيره فاصل قصير ان تجاهها
خلالك ناخذ العربيه وتابعونا عبر موقع
البرنامج
كما صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيس بوك
وايضا القمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا مع تصفيات بناء نموذج في
الموسم التاسع من نجوم العلوم مجددا مع
ضيفنا في البرنامج صادق قاسم صادق خلال
المواجهتين اللي شفته قبل شوي مع محمد
الجفيري واحمد نبيل من الكويت شنو اكثر شي
اه انطباعك هل مثلا ال المشاريع نفسها ام
الدفاع المشترك
المعيارين اللي تفضل فيه هو المشاريع
نفسهم يعني كل مشروع ي يخدم شريحه كبيره
اه عندنا الاخ محمد
يخدم شريحه مائه وخمسين الف اما دكتور
احمد نبيل ي يخدم شريحه جدا مهمه اللي
الجراحين اثناء العمليات اه اما بالنسبه
حق الدفاع كل واحد قاعد نشوف النجاح ياخذ
وقتا طويلا ما هو يرد على تساؤلات لجنه
التحكيم وان كانت انه في بعض الاسئله
للمشتركين اثنين اتهم ما جاء وابو عليها
بشكل مباشر
عليها طيب ال ال انا ب جواب مباشر بالنسبه
لكل المشاريع المستقبليه عندي مشروع انشاء
الله راح ينزل عشره
عمليه التطوير سنتين وهو يختص في احد
التقاليد والعادات اللي احنا نمارسها بشكل
يومي في منطقه الخليج صادقت هنالك ان شاء
الله كل التوفيق شخصيا عن نفسه صراحه
مسلحه من مشروعك اللي شاركت في العلوم
اللي هو لفحص العيارات البتروليه لان او
غيره من محبين القهوه العربيه بشكل كبير
جدا في هذا الموسم احد المشتركين يعشق
القهوه العربيه ويريد ان تكون في متناول
الجميع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للقوه العربيه
بالحفاظ على نكهتها الصور
ولصقها من البلده قرر
موسى ابتكر جهاز خاصا بصب القهوه العربيه
بالطريقه التقليديه يحرر منصبها يدويا
ويحافظ على نكهتها العربيه الاصيله مع
الاسف القهوه العربيه اصبحت عالميه
انا مجموعه
منافسه
النظر والتحليل من اجل التحليل التحليل
التنفيذ من كان تحليله محرك كان تنفيذها
مسرح بدنا نعبر عربيه اليا استخدام
الصعوبه اختراع الهندسه
العربيه ما في اي جهاز وبيقدمها الجهه
العربيه اسلوب ثقافه العراق الامتحان
بعد شهرين
الله ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
بس
عم بيعمل
هذا شيء معمول قبل ما في
يعني امر
سواء على هذا مثل ما قلت لك انا يا رجل
خائف عليه اكثر من امي
اليوم طبعا رسمي مختلف وموقع منها هو
اتقدم الى ساعدت كمان المواطن المغلوب على
امره وسام وذلك لطلب واحد بسيط يرحمهم
مرحبا
الفنجان وهذا شيء بسيط يعني انشاء الله
شيء بسيط
مستقل عن عم يعملوا مع كخبير
يعني حاولوا يعملوا من الخبره
بسيطه
جامعتين
وانا خط الدراسه تحاول تتعقد الامور
ونجحت بتعقيد
يعني تقول عنها بسيطه انا باكد لك انه
هايدي هاي بدايه
بعد زيارته سوا لفؤاد استمروا وسام في
تطوير منتج ولكن هل تخلي فعلا عن فكره
الربط المتحرك
تحت الطلب الثله الربو للقهوه العربيه
شكرا على مساهمتك العظيمه بدي اساله
الاليه اذا كانت مليانه
تقريبا ما بين ثمانيه الى سته
وثمانين
فيها الست الى ثمانيه وطالب يكونوا
بيظلوا انه هايدي ان موجودين
شو بيصير فيه
ممكن
هلا
مثل ها القوه اللي قدامي
طيب فيك تقولي
اول فنجان ليس بيبرم هذا الموضوع تسعه
وخمسين مع اول
وخمسين درجه
اربعه
تقريبا بيزيد ما بين ثلاثه الى اربعه في
كل مره واربعه فرجينيا
اللي عندكم
الدرجات ثلاثه درجات
المشكل هو السؤال
وبحسب
بسرعه و يطلع الناتج انا ما كنت قاعد احسن
كمان
يمكن توقع
القهوه وبدو يخلص
وتحرك وتحرك وتحرك ما بين ثلاثه الى اربع
سنين تتحرك واربعمائه
اربعه الخطه على ال الخطه على الارض
يعني
اللي انا عن الجانب تحركها لا لا لا
لا بدي كافه معك او الفنجان بتحرك
يتحرك هو ال ال
تابعوا يتحرك فيه
انا انا لانه انت نقطه
مرحله
فيها
انا اقول لك هايدي المعادله يا اللي كنت
ان تكون عملها الارقام الارقام
ما اعتقد ان
اسمعها لانها هي المعادله
هو اللي اعطاني كثير كان كريم اذا وراى
الدكتور زهير اعطاء الحزب دكتور خالد
ليسمع ان يعطيني نفس الكميه لكل الزبونات
ببعضهم صعوبه في موضوع انه القدره الدوله
بيتغير
المعادله
فرصه ذهبيه ببرنامج باريز ما تعمل شيء
كثير
علمي وتعرف الجواب على الاسئله وتاتي نفس
كميته الى كل المشاركين بدون ما يكون فيه
على الجوانب وتعطيني جواب على لانه هلا
والاشياء المائه
ليش ما
بتعمل لا بس
وهايدي الشيء اللي قلت لك انه منوهين
وهايدا علمي دقيق ما عملتوا
انعمل استمرت فهناك بيشتغل
انتوني ولا صار شغال مثل ما لازم يشرب
لانه ما كان عندنا
هايدا اللي انا برايي اذا عمل
عربيه في اللجان وبالتالي في عندك
ان ابنتك هيذي كلها وبدنا
اللاعب اللي انت عملت بنقول نحنا م نعتذر
منك لانه وج هناك بالطريقه الخطا
بدي شوف
فاجات انهم قالوا انهم كانوا وما كان في
المكان هذا الشيء مكتب
انا اقول انه
مليار لانه خلاص يشتغل لحاله وانت تعرف
بانه
اه بدي ارجع من جديد
نجاد يقول لا خلاص على كده
اذا ما اذا ما احنا خلاص انتهت
لكن حتى
من ان يكون في انفجار
او كما رحب التمر
الان الاول
[تصفيق]
دكتور فؤاد المزار المقاله اسمع كلام
انفسنا الكلام هم الازمات الكترونيكس وحتى
ربما بفتكر
على الفنجان انا اللي هلا شفته وان تعملوا
بايدك يعني بحييك ان كانت مهندس عندك
مهارات انا برايي
على ايديكم
كنا انتهينا ب ماشيين اكثر بكثير من
شايفوا انما هل انتهينا
او غير مكتمله انا برايي بس ما عملت
اختراع انت برايك هم فيه اختراق اذا بتجيب
انا سنه ثالثه هندسه الاتصالات او
الكهرباء
بيقدر يعملها تماما ولا لا
يعني هذا بديهي للناس والاختصاص
بينما هناك التحدي هناك هذا الفارق بين
الاختراق وبين التمرين مع كل الملاحظات
اللي اخذتها لاني اه
جيد
وانشاء الله
بها الوقت نحنا راح نشرب قهوه عربيه
[موسيقى]
خلينا نشوف
كي تصبح القهوه العربيه عالميه اختبار ان
ينجح اليوم يوم الاختبار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المره
بدنا نلاحظ انه الكميه
بالنسبه ل لتامين بدي اخذ بفتكر التايم
كان كثير اللي صدرت ثمانيه ناجين بس مانو
ملايين
انا بس بدي
يعطيك العافيه يا اخي تعودنا من واحنا
صغار الكلمه العربي تم نفس مقدار الجهه
لكن قاعدين شوفنا المقدار عندك
حال الامه العربيه وضعا حال الامه العربيه
منذ القدم الى الان ال كرم الضيافه العربي
لم يتغير لم يتغير لا عند تغيير ما تغير
المواجهه اللي صارت من اعضاء لجنه تحكيم
اكيد
الله
ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك
اذن مواجهات الليله انتهت وحان وقت
التصويت والكل متشوق اكيد لمعرفه النتائج
فاصل تابعونا فيه على موقع البرنامج في
التايمز
وصفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيس بوك وتويتر
خليكم معنا
ام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مصير الثلاثه يحدد الان
اكيد الكل يعرف ان مشترك واحد فقط سيغادر
البرنامج واضح للكل عضو في لجنه التحكيم
مرشح مفضل للخروج من البرنامج من سيتاهل
مرحله تقييم الاسواق ومن سيغادرنا نهائيا
محمد احمد
تفضل
هنالك ان شاء الله كل التوفيق في هذه
اللحظات الحاسمه التي لا تملكها بايديكم
وانما في الاجهزه التي بين ايدي اعضاء
لجنه التحكيم
اعضاء اللجنه الموقعين تفضلوا بالتصويت
الله
شكرا ل اعضاء لجنه التحكيم محمد احمد
تعرفون قوانين قواعد اللعبه واحد فقط يجب
عليه الخروج من هذه المرحله ولو تقاربت
النتائج ولو تقاربت المجهودات من بينكم
ولو حتى تقارب الاراء اعضاء لجنه التحكيم
في تقييمكم بالنهايه حتى لو كان الفارق
عشر نقطه يجب على واحد منكم المغادره
مستعدين
راح على الان عن الشخص الذي سيخرج خارج
اسوار برنامج نجوم العلوم في موسم التاسع
وللاسف وبكل احترام وتقدير لشخصه الكريم
جاءت النتائج
بخروج
وساءهم من هذه المرحله هناك ان شاء الله
كل التوفيق خارج اسوار برنامج نجوم العلوم
اما المركز الاول احمد ومحمد اسم ان ثلاثه
ما دائما منذ ان عرفنا هما
محمد واحمد
نتائج كم سته وثمانين لكم انتم الاثنان
وبالتالي ليس هناك اول وثاني
جزيلا لكم هذه المرحله مشاهدينا الكرام لم
تنتهي بعد مشتركين اخرين سيخوضون التجربه
نفسها في الاسبوع المقبل تابعونا عبر موقع
البرنامج
وصفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيسبوك تويتر
وانستقرام اما الان استودعكم الله مثلما
على الوضع دائما نتيجه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعتقد
شخصيه جدا
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
نخسر
صداقات تثبت للعالم اختار
راح تتخلى باذن الله في كل بيت راح يكون
اول واحد
برنامج نهايه هذه اشياء جديده
[موسيقى]